at the end of the day the family stands  together were united we're there for  each other keeping up with the  kardashians has returned to its filming  schedule following a short hiatus after  Kim's traumatizing robbery at gunpoint  in Paris earlier this month who was  really tough for me a source close to  production confirms two et the reality  TV family is back to filming everyone  except for Kim and what is the rapist  Kourtney made her first public  appearance since the scary incident at a  cocktail party in West Hollywood  Wednesday night celebrating skincare  line man you cut doctor and I witnessed  lzt - keeping up with the Kardashian  cameras were rolling at the venue mom  Kris Jenner was also at the event  she and Kourtney were spotted having a  happy intimate conversation as they shot  a scene together  Kourt also gave et an update on Kim's  upcoming birthday Friday revealing there  are no plans set yet so we'll just have  to wait and see  you